estamos de regreso para conocer las
principales noticias en materia
económica de américa latina y del resto
del mundo y por eso nos acompaña por
supuesto daniela hablando muy buenas
noches
danny comenzamos en argentina donde ella
es ley no la ley de modificación del
impuesto a las ganancias hola santiago
buenas noches mire este es un impuesto
que ya se aplica a todas las ganancias
que tenga una persona en un año fiscal a
partir de determinado monto antes del
mínimo era de 75 mil pesos y de 99 mil
pesos netos dependiendo de si la persona
tiene hijos o no ahora ese mínimo será
de 150 mil pesos brutos o 120 mil netos
que equivalen a unos 1600 dólares a
precio de hoy así lo reza la
modificación de la ley de origen
oficialista que aprobó el congreso y que
este martes fue promulgada por el
presidente alberto fernández el gobierno
dice que un poco más de 12 millones de
personas van a dejar de pagar este
impuesto y que 9 de cada 10 ciudadanos
estará exento de ahora en adelante
además la ley santiago es retroactiva
así que se devuelve el dinero que se
haya descontado en el primer trimestre
cómo avanza bueno vamos de argentina a
su vecina chile donde ya está en la
recta final el proyecto de retiro de
pensiones sí señor ya lo avaló la cámara
de diputados- y este martes lo hizo la
comisión constitucional del senado ahora
pasará al pleno de ese organismo pero el
trámite legislativo no garantiza que sea
ley recordemos que el gobierno de
sebastián piñera tiene que sancionarlo y
anunció que recurrió hoy al tribunal
constitucional para tratar de frenarlo
se trata del tercer retiro en menos de
un año de un 10 por ciento del ahorro
pensional una medida muy criticada por
el ejecutivo y por los economistas según
la superintendencia de pensiones de
hecho cerca de 5 millones de afiliados
casi la mitad no va a tener recursos en
esta oportunidad para sacar su vemos en
el continente vamos a eeuu para hablar
de un juicio multimillonario contra
cuatro farmacéuticas de qué se trata
santiago los condados de santa clara los
ángeles y orange además de la ciudad de
oakland todos en california exigen 50
mil millones de dólares en
indemnizaciones
el alegan que cuatro farmacéuticas entre
ellas johnson y johnson nitiva
farmacéutica ayudaron a causar la
mortífera epidemia de opioides en ese
país que resultó en medio millón de
muertes por sobredosis durante dos
décadas en el inicio de un nuevo vídeo
juicio virtual por ahora sin jurado los
demandantes aseguran que estas empresas
comercializaron engañosamente esos
medicamentos y minimizaron sus riesgos
adictivos su contraparte dice que estos
medicamentos serán apenas una pequeña
parte del mercado y que siempre
advirtieron de los riesgos a los médicos
hoy existen más de 3000 demandas a nivel
nacional por la crisis de opioides pero
el único caso que llegó a juicio
efectivamente hizo que johnson y johnson
tuviera que pagar 465 millones de
dólares al estado de oklahoma en 2019
vamos a hablar ahora de una semana de
resultados en wall street' verdad bueno
la primera semana los grandes bancos
anunciaron grandes ganancias sólidos
resultados el turno ahora es para las
otras industrias este martes y un aire
de airlines se reportó pérdidas por mil
160 millones de dólares aunque cayeron
frente al año pasado por el año por el
lado positivo johnson y johnson una de
las desarrolladoras de vacunas reportó
un crecimiento del 7 por ciento en sus
ganancias hasta los 6.200 millones de
dólares y procter and gamble también la
subió a más de 3 mil 200 millones esto
gracias a la obsesión por la limpieza
durante la pandemia esta empresa dijo
que la demanda de sus productos en eeuu
pues prevé una subida de sus precios
porque han aumentado los costos de las
materias primas una medida similar ya la
había tomado su competidor kimberly
clark esto afectará a productos de
higiene para bebés y mujeres y también
los pañales para adultos santiago
continuamos con los indicadores de la
jornada que dicen wall street del cerro
en rojo con el mercado más pendiente del
avance del hobbit 19 que de los
resultados empresariales esa misma
preocupación se trasladó a los mercados
europeos en donde bolsas como la de
parís y madrid bajaron más del 2% y en
américa latina la bolsa de sao paulo
cerró en rojo por segundo día
consecutivo
para finalizar como siempre cuál es la
cifra del día los 8 mil empleos que
recortará caixabank que se convirtió en
el banco nacional más grande de españa
tras la compra de bankia esto representa
casi una quinta parte de su plantilla
también va a cerrar mil 534 sucursales
todo esto por la pandemia santiago
daniela relatar muchísimas gracias
aportarnos las principales noticias en
materia económica a nuestra audiencia
limitamos a continuar informando se en
el resto de nuestra programación y en
france 24 punto com
[Música]